there's this um
there's this check that used to work for
me a number of years ago and you know
she was telling me her um
fiance i mean
you guys would like this story um was
taking these pills and you know to try
to keep his hair and i mean it was kind
of working but then she also started to
complain that his sexual function
went in the toilet and that's when she
started hitting on me big time too right
so
is that a is that a side effect that
affects all men is it some men like
how does that work
that's the million dollar question i
mean like what's the point having hair
if you're not you know able to perform
right right because i mean you want to
have hair to look good i would imagine
so so we wrote an article literally last
week so this is again you know perfect
timing and no richard and i planned this
two months ago
but we wrote an article last week my
copywriter and i on the dangers of dht
and
estrogen inhibition
in both men and women okay now i won't
go into estrogen inhibition today but
this means for all of you guys who use
testosterone or bodybuilders who use
therapeutics at whatever we've already
covered that in cast before
blocking your estrogen by using an ai is
literally killing you it's shortening
your lifespan that's not debatable
anymore the science is very conclusive
on that so if you're using an ai and
you're watching the show right now stop
immediately or you're shortening your
lifespan i will definitely mention that
all the bodybuilders who have died in
the last two months without mentioning
names i could guarantee you that if you
did an autopsy and you looked at their
vasculature you would see micro fissures
in all of those vascular lines which led
to their heart
attack slash disease and why they died
and this is all because they were using
serms and ais that's a whole other
conversation for another day but i work
with the world's leading expert on that
name dr scott howell
okay he is the world's leading androgen
and epidemiologist
he can conclusively prove that if you're
blocking your estrogen you're short your
lifespan now in that same article
blocking dihydrotestosterone which is
dht
is also
damaging your cellular end caps or your
telomeres as you and i already talked
about earlier in the show that you use a
petal on for so you're literally
damaging
the cellular life that you have in your
dna by doing all these things and again
without going into details it's all in
the article
all the science is in the article so for
men and women who are using and by the
way richard a lot of women are using dht
inhibitors it's really sad hormones
yeah they suffer from hormonal hair loss
and of course the docs write them
scripts for that too oh so they get
scripts for finasteride
really yeah okay crazy yeah it's insane
but so here's the thing if you're using
these because you asked the original
question
do all men and women who use these
suffer from sexual dysfunction no and
that's what's so weird is that there are
some people that don't but the great
majority who are honest
do
and there is actually as you know
richard a syndrome now recognized by the
medical industry called pfs post
finasteride syndrome
that men and women suffer from from
using these mostly men it's mostly shown
in men but there are a lot of women that
have this issue who become literally
clinically depressed
and even after cessation of using these
horrible toxic drugs
never recover
i've actually lost two close personal
friends
to suicide
who used dht inhibitors for a long time
in their life
and suffered you know from pfs were in
forums were in communities with other
men and they killed themselves okay now
this goes back 10 years
when it was a lot less known and i knew
nothing about dht inhibition causing
this issue but now we know
and so the bottom line is is if you are
a man or a woman and i'm sure you have a
lot of women that watch your show bro
now and you're using dht inhibitors
stop
immediately
now now we're going to talk on how you
can withdraw and again richard's going
to link an article that we've already
written with one of the world's top
doctors on how it's on your website on
your blog right because i didn't i
didn't dig them up from the email so if
you guys go to it's jaycampbell.com it's
actually somebody cybersquatting online
it's j a y middle initial c so jc
campbell.com jason okay yeah so it's on
his blog and it's the most recent ones
i'm gonna i'm gonna dig him up through
the email and i'll put him in the
description after the show
so ben just so you know so ben
greenfield um wanted to launch these
articles from his site because he's
obviously got a lot more viewers and a
lot more people visiting a site than
mine
so he launched part one and part two of
this article in june
and as far as i know there were two of
the most read articles ever in the
history of his site right so then we
took the full article and we put it on
my site but you guys can google this and
it'll come up you know with attribution
to ben and as you just said too you know
nick and i did a podcast with ben
talking about this back in june and it
was you know it's a firestorm now a lot
of doctors in the hair loss world even
hair transplant surgeons
are new to this information
okay and this is like i said this is a
disruptive
you know
methodology and theory but it's backed
by science and it will be borne out by
the evidence and proven that this is
correct so
what we came to the conclusion in the
article of richard is that dht
inhibition is at best a secondary
downstream effect
of hair loss
prevention but it almost does nothing in
hair regrowth and obviously any person
who is desiring to regrow their natural
hair has to use agents that will do that
again increa increasing red blood cell
or at red blood flow to the scalp and
that's what we'll talk about next
all right um i've got
i don't know can i show them the
pictures here jay yeah absolutely um
here i sent you a picture
a few weeks ago because because i just
run out of the stuff that you had sent
me and i was like let me just see what
it looks like i wasn't i mean you don't
notice any differences you're spraying
some stuff on your on your face or your
hair like day by day but i did do a
before picture and then after
um
i'll show you mine first and mine isn't
as uh profound as what jay's was i'll
show you jays in a second but
that's
that's what i had uh sent out i don't
know that was like a month ago or a few
weeks sorry that was october 20th so
that was uh about three or four weeks
ago so this is the before shot of my
scalp and this is the after shot um
it's it's more hair for sure and the and
the one thing i mean i wasn't expecting
much to you know to begin with because
i'm like yeah yeah you know whatever
this stuff okay fine send it over jay
let me try it out but after i looked at
the after picture and i sent it over to
i was like huh
it looks like this stuff works and i
know that it worked a lot better on you
than it did on me
the other thing too is and i'll just be
honest with you you guys know that
around that i'm on therapeutic
testosterone but i've also used
primobolin you know during the summer
time as well you know for about six to
eight weeks on top of my therapeutic
testosterone which which is which
increases dht right in in your serum
blood levels which is great for
um you know building muscle and losing
fat and they stack really well together
um
i'm a fan of it i get good results from
it um vigorous steve i don't know if you
know steve
uh
it sounds familiar maybe probably he's
this dutch guy that lives in uh thailand
i did a uh cast with him about a month
or two ago he's got great information on
his youtube channel what's his last name
um i don't know what his last name is
but his youtube channel is vigorous
steve huh you need to connect me with it
sounds awesome yeah yeah um and and he
loves stacking you know uh testosterone
with primo ball and like that's his
go-to so i was like yeah
i'm gonna give this a try the side
effect is
if you're predisposed to losing hair
due to androgenic alopecia then it's
just gonna accelerate it i'm like
whatever i don't care i just shave my
head
even even with primobolan i still ended
up with um you know like a little more
density than what i had you know before
which is all fine and
the other thing i noticed too i don't
know if you can tell by the pigment
because i because i was looking at the
comments and somebody noticed it over
here too and they said something along
of skin skin looks healthier
and he's right you know the skin tone
here
is way
um
like more
i don't know how to define it but it
just looks healthier than it did before
and that's as a byproduct of the hair
product plus the skin product i mean
we'll talk about the skin peptides as
well but those are my results here's um
here's jay's let me try to go i think
it's on the product page now um yeah
just go to box okay yeah because you
guys have like uh eyelash stuff and
that's the left one right there
top top left this one here yeah
um
and by the way these pictures are old
too now so i mean like my my regrowth is
even more pronounced it's pretty crazy i
think i think you might buy it
where is it did they take it there it is
right there so
that was you
before you started to grow your hair
back you actually started to lose your
hair yeah then you shaved your head then
you got that
that's mantis right there that's vance's
okay so that's after you did the scalp
micro pigmentation that's literally dude
that's so my as you remember my hair was
like patchy when you and i met each
other in 2019 remember i just had like
patches of hair and i even told you do
you have a do you have a before and
after picture of like vantis
i i do so i would just tell you just
like all you do is go on my channel and
search my podcast i mean you'll see my
hair
you know the way it was and then you
know the guys at vantis were like bro
just come down here because i i
literally was like you i was like you
know [ __ ] this i'm going to just go
chrome here it is here it is i found it
yeah so let's so let's show your scalp
before you actually got the micro
pigmentation because that's like the
head tattoo thing totally uh here we go
so add to stream because this will give
you a clearer picture of what his head
looked like before he got it tattooed
does it look exactly right crying out
loud there we go so that's before here
right that's perfect yep yeah so that's
it right there so you can see when my
hair would grow back i'd have patches
yeah
yep okay that's exactly right so that's
where i was going to go i was just going
to stay with fantus and be like cool
and just keep your head
the story is a listener
uh was listening to ben greenfield's
podcast he was talking to ian mitchell
the guy who's a big c60 guy and he's
like hey man c60 works to regrow hair
all you have to do is put in your hair
and that's the peptide that you're
talking about
carbon 60. carbon 60 is like the main
ingredient in it right
it's along with the ghk which is the
copper peptide but yeah so this guy
calls this up and he's like dude check
my hair out i've been using carbon 60
and uh and ghk together he was using um
a script version of uh ghkcu
and when he sent the pictures to me and
nick we were like that's [ __ ]
there's no way
and you know so then nick's like all
right well you know being the guinea pig
that he was i'll start testing it and
then he said it to me
and
the rest is history
i mean it's like holy [ __ ] and as you
know when we launched this product in
2020 and june 5th
we sold out completely in the first
month and then when we got it back
which was the secondary version because
the first version was mct oil carbon 60.
now everybody who follows us knows the
story and it was too thick it still
worked great but it was mct oil is
constitutionally too thick and it would
make your hair too greasy so version two
was what it is now and we're improving
this by the way coming but uh it's grape
seed oil extract so you know that it's a
very thin mist of an oil again it's oil
based in the carbon 60 and then serum b
serum a is copper peptide which is like
a blue mist in a water base why does it
have to be in two separate bottles like
because because right now it's a good
question um
when we got our patent you know it's a
provisional patent and we're working on
the permanent patent we had to cover
multiple delivery systems
and in order to get it to a place where
we could actually get it into people's
hands so we could help them right away
the only way we could do it was to have
two versions the aqueous which is the
carbon
excuse me the copper peptide gh kcu and
that's serum a and then serum b
which is carbon 60 is an oil based you
know nanomolecule and the only way you
can actually put that into solution
is oil now version three which is coming
from us next year probably pretty soon
sooner rather than later will be a
one-phase product and it'll be liposomal
so a liposomal product you can put an
oil-based solution inside an aqueous
based solution and they will stay
together and they will not separate so
that's just a formulation thing and
that's coming
but you know as you know once we
launched in
same time it's crazy i'm having
flashbacks but we launched on black
friday version two last year and we sold
out in two days
and every single body and we see the
bottle that we shipped which were really
high-end bottles by the way had gold
tips and everything
broke because the peptides expanded in
the neck of the bottle in our
manufacturer not our manufacturer but
our 3pl our logistics company in kansas
city because
at the end of november early december
last year they had a 20 degree below
zero cold snap come through and so
they're all sitting there at the
facility to go out we had this huge
black friday stay when they broke
and for two months
all i got was emails from people saying
hey bro
i'm gonna need a refill got a got a
question from santiago he's asking so
what peptide might be used instead of
finasteride do you mix microneedling so
the peptide is right right there and
here i'll i'll drop it in the live chat
but it's also in the description so if
you guys go to the description of the
video there's a link to asir custom and
jay was kind enough to give me a uh a 15
coupon code so use rich 15 on the
checkout if you want to grab some of
this stuff um
what about microneedling like what's
your position on that so that's an
amazing question so my official jay
campbell and richard cooper
position is use micro needling
but from a jay campbell co-founder you
know of asir custom i can't go on my
website and say that because it's a
quote-unquote invasive procedure and
then we would have to be considered you
know a clinical product by the fda so
microneedling and um what's the other
thing that you do um that people always
talk about derma rolling rolling so
microneedling and derma rolling is a
profound
enhancement to our product now one other
thing and i want to go deep on this how
long we got we still got 15 minutes
right um
yeah i can probably go for about another
25 or so okay awesome so the other thing
that's important
to really dramatic because now we're
talking about okay hair regrowth okay we
already know that we don't want to use
dht inhibitors to
suppress dihydrotestosterone and let me
take a step back because we didn't cover
this and this is important you'd never
want to block any kind of god-made
biological process estrogen
dihydrotestosterone only bad things come
about when you're suppressing again
natural biological systems but you you
already said it but i'll go deeper and
again this is in the article when you
suppress dihydrotestosterone you limit
synaptic dendritic serotonergic
i mean basically every brain pathway
that's necessary for cognition and mood
are being hammered
so
and this is again it's in the article
and again i'm trying not to scare you
guys it's not my my intention but
you are literally creating amyloid
plaque buildup
by suppressing dihydrotestosterone which
as you guys know is what leads to
neurodegenerative disorder alzheimer's
dementia right parkinson's lou gehrig's
i mean all these things are horrific
if you're doing this so again
stop using the hd inhibitors
start focusing on how do i improve blood
flow to my scalp so with our product
which again is called oxander grow
you can derma roll micro needle
you can even just aggressively massage
your hair and your scalp every day now
what would be the sequence with micro
needling or derma rolling when applying
a product like this your scalp is is it
before
then you wait then you apply is that you
apply then you do the rolling or the or
the micro needling like what's the
sequence for that
i mean
there's no real right answer i mean you
could do both i mean you could
definitely micro needle put on serum a
which is water-based um and then massage
that in and then put on you know wait
three minutes or whatever for the water
to absorb into the skin i mean it really
also depends on the level of the micro
needling and derma rolling you're doing
like if you do like a one mil or one and
a half mil exactly if you're tearing the
skin fibers of the scalp of the dermis
of the scalp and you're you know causing
blood
um then you know you're probably going
to want to put in agent a and agent b
you know within the first 90 seconds to
two minutes of doing that but if you get
if you're going slower and a lot of
people do this really really slow
i would put in the water base first
because the water base is going to
absorb faster and then which is crma and
then put in serum b which is the oil
base after
a lot of guys and obviously this is not
you but if you can look at my hair right
now you can see that i have like it
looks like i have product in my hair
okay
this is serum b
so serum b when you put in a lot of guys
comment on this chris gethin talks about
this all the time
he uses as a product he's like dude the
best part about oxano is like i don't
have to use [ __ ] products in my hair
to push up my hair anymore i just use
serum b and it's like this thin
you know texturized product and it keeps
your hair standing up if that's what you
want to do so
that's one of the other uh advantages
but one thing that you know kind of
breaking on your show and there's a
little bit about this from some people
who have experimented with this you can
also use red light okay because red
light therapy was asking about red light
therapy so red light therapy increases
angiogenesis which again is the increase
of red blood cells red blood flow to the
scalp right we remember the spectrum of
red light that you want to use again
like i know the juve lights kind of have
it built in like is it just by default
just get a juve light juve is j-o-o-v by
the way dude so the owners of juve are
good personal friends of mine so yes but
in truth and
and this is scott by the way the owner
of juve i mean you know they'll tell you
that um it doesn't matter you know
there's people out there now saying that
oh flicker rate is everything with red
light that's bs i mean the smart people
that create red light devices and
products as long as it's a you know a
good not some alibaba that you paid 9.99
for you know most red light devices are
going to work but yes juve is standard
it's a gold standard i have a jube i
have a full body juve in my house i even
have the portable one but that's what i
would do you know ben i think now works
for the company and correct me if i'm
wrong and ben don't get mad at me if i'm
wrong i think their bio light i think is
what he uses and they got the portables
so you can literally put it on give
yourself three minutes four minutes like
this
and and do that every single day and i'm
so so here's you know here's where i am
on whether or not you're going to get
results
um
80 of people who have active hair
follicles get results
i would classify you as only having some
active follicles you clearly have pieces
where you don't have air active
follicles and even in the places where
you didn't have many it regrew right now
it's
it's definitely better because i was
going to ask you like it would be
definitely better to start using this
early phase hair loss than like i would
be late phase whatever you know like i
started noticing my hair loss in my
early to mid 20s
so
right like had i had a product like this
like i used midoxidol that thing didn't
do anything that's garbage they're all
worthless yeah
like this sort of stuff you can put in
your scalp like early stage so if you've
got hair still like you know like what
do you do you spray it on your hand you
kind of massage it like through
your scalp or that's like so that's the
importance is
a lot of guys and women and again this
works amazing for women that have you
know you got pictures here on the site
of of a woman's head as well too like
over here before and after and yeah this
dude over here clearly
is a big influencer in florida he's had
i mean you should see what his hair
looks like now that was after one month
but anyway so so here's the truth
to your question
if you have longer hair and you're in
the initial stages of thinning you
definitely can do two things in in about
two weeks all octano products are going
to have a dropper so right now they're
sprays right but you'll have a dropper
so if you are a woman
and you just want to hit in the ends or
something like that you just drop it in
your hand go like this and boom right
rub it in massage it in but you you hit
on it it's a scalp health product
okay so it's not
and richard here's more of the scam and
you remember because you and i are
similar you know almost the same age
like in the back in the old days they
had the bosley hair institute and they
had like freaking moose right like they
had a moose product that they would push
have people put in their hair
that doesn't do jack [ __ ]
if you do not get a product that you
know technically will help and obviously
none of those did but if you have a real
product that include includes red blood
cell flow to your scalp
you have to get it into the scalp it
can't go into the ends of the hair the
follicles will absolutely not help they
improve the health of your scalp so the
only way you're going to get regrowth is
actually to
improve the soil think of the scalp the
dermis of your scalp is the soil so you
now have to like you know
churn up the soil and then get these
nutrients that increase again
angiogenesis red blood cell formation
collagen synthesis all these things so
that you will improve the health of your
natural skin
of your uh
the top of your uh scalp so that you
regrow the hair and again anyone can
regrow their hair
provided that they reduce inflammation
now even if i did i mean like pretty
much anybody can do it because i didn't
well dude i would be willing to bet and
i know you're not going to because you
look good without hair but if you did
like a serious one-year deal next year
when version three comes because i'll
tell you what keep
keep sending me the product and i'll
keep using it and i'll stay off the
primobolin during that time
well i mean that would happen but if we
did a test with you i'm pretty sure that
you could regrow your hair to a level
where you'd be like wow all right
well i'll tell you this i mean like
right now like i can feel a lot more
follicles on my head like my girlfriend
sometimes just sits there just like kind
of like rubbing my head and she's like
it feels like you got a little more hair
up there now right it's like
it's not obvious you know to most people
but i mean like that small change is
it's somewhat different for a guy like
me to notice but for guys like you that
had more to begin with or other guys
that might have a lot more than you had
to begin with
it seems like it works so i mean i can
only co-sign it from that perspective i
mean you guys know that i only talk
about stuff that i've got personal
experience with i don't i don't feel
like look there are some people there
are definitely some people that it will
not work for and you know they will send
me an email or send the company an email
and say hey man i gave it my best shot
it didn't work and again i'm going to
say this and this is where it's
important
if you are a metabolic disaster
if you're obese
you have if you have any comorbidities
if you're diabetic
copd you know you're a smoker
you drink too much alcohol any of these
things you have
heavy levels of systemic inflammation
our products
imitate or mimic the cellular health of
you as the end user so if you are like
richard or me and you have low body fat
and you give a [ __ ] about your health
you're going to get better results than
somebody who doesn't so this is not an
easy button
magic pill potion that is going to
regrow your hair if you're fat and you
have
massive levels of inflammation forget it
don't buy our product it won't work i'll
still say this so man like i'm looking
at this picture over here like you've
got slightly more than what i had a few
years ago here okay exactly so
i mean you know check it out
you